hi everyone
this is professor m science and today i
want to discuss symmetric
and antisymmetric states in another one
of our videos on rigorous quantum
mechanics
in quantum systems of identical
particles exchanging any two particles
leads to exactly the same physics
and this can happen in two ways
symmetric states are quantum states that
don't change at all when you exchange
two particles
antisymmetric states are states that
only change by a sign
when you exchange two particles it may
sound like a trivial preoccupation but
these states play a fundamental role in
quantum mechanics
they capture the key difference between
bosons and fermions
in this video we'll do three things
first we will learn what symmetric and
antisymmetric states are
second we will learn how to build
symmetric and antisymmetric states
and third we will learn about related
concept symmetric
operators so let's go
let's consider an n particle system and
the state space v made of the tensor
products over n single particle state
spaces
let's also consider the n factorial
permutation operators p
alpha associated with n particles
we first define a totally symmetric
state psi plus
if p alpha acting on a state psi plus
gives psi plus for any alpha
then this state is a totally symmetric
state
conceptually this means that applying
any permutation of the n particles gives
back the same state we started with
total asymmetric state leaving a
subspace of the full state space
called v plus next let's define a
totally
anti-symmetric state psi minus
if p alpha acting on a state psi minus
gives eta
alpha psi minus for any alpha where eta
alpha is plus 1 if p
alpha is an even permutation and -1 if p
alpha is an odd permutation then psi
minus is a totally antisymmetric state
remember from the video and permutation
operator that the parity of a
permutation is the parity of the number
of transpositions
into which we can write out a
permutation conceptually this means that
the permutation of the n particles gives
back the same state
we started with if the permutation
corresponds to exchanging pairs of
particles an even number of times
and the negative of the state we started
with if the permutation corresponds to
exchanging pairs of particles an odd
number of times
totally anti-semitic states live in a
subspace of the full state space
called v minus so why do we care about
these totally symmetric and totally
antisemitic states
in the video on the symmetrization
postulate i explain how identical
particles in quantum mechanics
can only be in either totally symmetric
or totally anti-symmetric states
so these states are fundamental in
studying quantum systems of more than
one particle
and what i want to do in the rest of the
video is to figure out how to build
totally symmetric and totally
anti-semitic states
to build totally symmetric and totally
anti-symmetric states we first define
two new operators that project an
arbitrary state onto the two subspaces v
plus and v minus spanned by these states
we first define the operator s plus as
equal to 1 over
n factorial sum over alpha of p alpha
where the sum runs over all possible n
factorial permutations
the operator s plus projects onto v plus
so it creates totally symmetric states
and we call it the symmetrizer
we also define s minus as equal to 1
over
n factorial sum over alpha of eta alpha
p
alpha where again the sum runs over all
possible n factorial permutations
s minus projects onto v minus so it
creates totally
anti-symmetric states and we call it the
anti-symmetrizer
to show that these two operators do what
their name claims they do we first need
to show that they are projection
operators
to do this remember from the video on
projection operators that this means we
have to show that these two operators
square to themselves however before we
can prove this we need to prove an
intermediate result
for an arbitrary permutation p alpha we
have p alpha s
plus equals s plus p alpha and both
equal s
plus to prove this let's consider the
product of p
alpha and s plus which we write out
explicitly using the definition above
taking p alpha inside the sum we obtain
this expression
at this point we need to remember the
rearrangement theorem from group theory
that i discussed in the video on
permutation operators
the rearrangement theorem says that
multiplying a list of all elements of a
group by one of the group elements
in this case p alpha gives another list
in which all the group elements appear
once and only once
simply in a different order in our case
because this beta sum is over all
elements
and the action of b alpha simply
rearranges the terms then the sum
doesn't change and we obtain
s plus again this completes the proof
that p
alpha s plus equals s plus the same
argument can be shown to prove that s
plus p alpha equals s plus
we can also write down a similar
expression for s minus like this
and the proof is analogous so i won't
repeat it
with these results we're now ready to
calculate s plus squared
it is s plus times s plus we can write
out the first s-plus explicitly to get
this
we can then move the second s-plus
inside the sum because it doesn't
explicitly depend on alpha
and we get this this term is simply the
one up here
and we just showed it equals s plus so
we get this
s plus doesn't explicitly depend on
alpha so we can take it out
and we get this
this term is 1 because the sum has n
factorial terms as there are a total of
n factorial permutations
alpha and we're therefore dividing n
factorial by n factorial
finally we get s plus we can do the same
to show that s minus squared
is equal to s minus and then these two
results confirm that the symmetrizer and
anti-symmetrizer are projection
operators
using a similar proof we can also show
that s plus s minus equals zero
so that they project to orthogonal
subspaces
and finally adding s plus and s minus is
not equal to the identity
unless n equals two to show this you can
try out the sum explicitly for the n
equals two and then equals three cases
what this means is that the two
projectors don't project to
complementary subspaces
now that we know that the s operators
are projection operators all we have
left to show is that they respectively
project an arbitrary state onto a
totally symmetric
and a totally anti-symmetric state to
see this we consider a ket
psy prime obtained by the action of s
plus on an arbitrary ket
psi we then consider the action of an
arbitrary permutation p
alpha on psi prime we can then write
psi prime out explicitly like this then
we can use this property up here to
simplify it to this
and it is simply psi prime this means
that as claimed
psi prime is a totally symmetric state
for s minus we can define a psi prime
prime like this
we can then apply the permutation
operator p alpha on psi
prime prime then insert the definition
of psi prime prime
then use the second relation up here to
get this
and it is eta alpha psi prime prime
this allows us to confirm that s minus
psi is a totally
anti-symmetric state overall
the symmetrizer and anti-symmetrizer are
the operators that allow us to build
starting from arbitrary states totally
symmetric
and totally anti-symmetric states
another important property is that the
symmetrizer acting on any permutation of
a cat
psi gives the same totally symmetric cut
this can be shown by acting with s plus
on a permutation p alpha of
psi then again using the fact that this
gives s
plus the expression simplifies to this
so again what does this mean any
permutation of a cat
projects to the same totally symmetric
state
for the anti-symmetrizer acting on a
permutation of psi
we get a similar result so that any
permutation of a cat projects to the
same totally anti-symmetric state
possibly up to a sign
after discussing the relation between
permutations and totally symmetric and
antisymmetric states
we need to consider what happens to
observables
let's start with a simple example
corresponding to a two particle system
in this case the permutation operator
p21 exchanges the two particles
consider hermitian operator a1 that acts
on the single particle state space v1
and whose eigenvalue equation is a1
acting on eigenstate ui
equals eigenvalue ai multiplying
eigenstate ui
a1 is hermitian so its eigenstates form
a basis of v1
there is also an operator a2 acting on
v2 with the corresponding eigenvalue
equation
and the eigenstates also form a basis
for v2
now promote a1 to act on the tensor
product state space v
as usual and i will use this simplified
notation emitting the identity operator
and we can similarly promote a2 to act
on v
to understand the interplay between
permutations and general operators we
start by considering the combination p21
a1 p21 dagger we consider its action on
the basis state of v
which we can build as the tensor product
of the eigenstates of a1 and a2
as p21 is hermitian and it is simply the
action of the permutation operator
so we get this expression where the
particles are essentially exchanged
then we get the action of a1 on the
eigenstates from v1
which gives this and finally we act with
the p21 permutation operator to exchange
the particles back
in parallel consider the action of a2 on
the same basis
state a2 acts on the basis ket in v2
and we obtain this expression comparing
these two expressions we see that they
are the same
so that p21 a1 p21 dagger is equal to a2
in a similar way we can show that p21 a2
p21 dagger is equal to a1
so what does this mean the permutation
operator exchanges the action of an
operator from v1 to v2
and vice versa
these two results for the action of the
permutation operator on operators that
act only on v1 or only on v2 generalizes
two operators that act in the full
tensor product state space v for example
consider the operator c12
which is the sum over a1 and b2
remember that what we really mean by
this is the sum of the tensor product of
a1 with the identity in v2
and the tensor product of the identity
in v1 with b2
to see how c12 transforms on the
permutation operator
we start by explicitly writing out c12
in terms of a1 and b2
then we carry out the multiplication to
get this
then we get the action of the
permutation operator on a1 and b2
to get this and finally we can rewrite
it as c21
we can do the same for an operator d12
that is a product of a1 and b2
looking at how it transforms under
permutation we start with this
then we write out d12 we can then insert
p21 dagger
p21 in the middle here and we can do
this as this is the identity operator
because p21 is a unitary operator
then we can group the terms like this
and we get a to b1
that we can finally rewrite as d21
putting these results together we can
write down this general statement about
an observable
o12 acting in v that can be written in
terms of observables that act on v1
and v2 we're now ready to define
symmetric
observables a symmetric observable
is an observable for which o12 is equal
to o21 this definition is in fact
equivalent
to saying that the symmetric observable
is one that commutes with the
permutation operator
to see this consider the action of the
permutation operator on o12
which gives o to one we then insist that
the observable is symmetric
so it is equal to one two
we can then multiply by p to one from
the right on both sides of the equation
and we get this
this term gives simply the identity
because p21 is unitary so we obtain that
p21012
is equal to o12 p21
this implies that an observable that
commutes with the permutation operator
is a symmetric observable
we can generalize these results to
systems of n particles
and we define a totally symmetric
observable under exchange of indices
as one that commutes with all
permutations for the n-particle system
before we wrap up i want to emphasize
the importance of the ideas we have
discussed today
and you absolutely need to remember the
following a state
psi plus onto which any permutation p
alpha acts like this
is called a totally symmetric state what
this means conceptually
is that in a totally symmetric state
exchanging any two particles gives back
the same state
additionally the operator s-plus called
the symmetrizer
is the operator that allows us to build
a totally symmetric state by applying it
to an arbitrary state
similarly a state psi minus onto which
any permutation p
alpha acts like this where it alpha is
the parity of the permutation
is called the totally anti-symmetric
state
what this means conceptually is that in
a totally anti-symmetric state
exchanging any two particles gives back
the same state with an
extra minus sign so that overall
exchanging pairs of particles an
odd number of times gives an overall
minus sign and exchanging particles an
even number of times
gives the same state back the operator s
minus
called the anti-symmetrizer is the
operator that allows us to build
a totally anti-symmetric state totally
symmetric and totally anti-symmetric
states are the only allowed states of
systems of identical particles
this means they are fundamental in areas
ranging from condensed matter physics
material science to chemistry because
they all involve multi-particle systems
to continue your path in learning about
these exciting areas the next thing you
should check out
is the video on the symmetrization
postulate which relates symmetric and
asymmetric states
with bosons and fermions if you liked
the video or like send me suggestions
for future videos please subscribe